could the five-day working week become a
thing of the past for those at the Royal
Society of biology it already has
they were one of 61 organizations taking
part in the pilot and they're keeping
the four day week we see there's
actually been a decline in the amount of
sick days taken During the period of the
trial we were starting off sick leave at
around about the you know five four to
five days perhaps per person per year on
average it's down to less than two at
the moment so I think it's a really
substantial difference actually
employees now have a slightly longer
working day but they say it's worth it
weekends can be quite hectic the two-day
weekend so it's been quite nice to have
that extra day you see your friends and
family on the two days when they're also
free and then you get that extra day off
during the week just to do your chores
or just to have that time to yourself to
relax so it's really made a big
difference to my mental health I think
of the 2 900 staff who took part in the
pilot 39 said they were less stress
compared with the start of the trial the
number of sick days dropped by around
two-thirds and there was also a 57
decrease in the number of people leaving
companies compared with the same period
the previous year
the pandemic was key in forcing
workplaces to become more flexible but
not everyone believes a shorter week is
the future
I think a four day week sounds good in
principle but in practice how many
companies are going to be able to
actually support employees well-being if
they're going from having a normal
five-day week and then cramming that
down into four days we do a five day
week but we work 10 till four so we
shorten the days and that means that the
employees get to have that work-life
Harmony but they're not actually
shortening their weak with the findings
of the pilot being presented to the
House of Commons today your four day
week could be just around the corner
Alice Porter Sky News